if only the pioneers who conquered these
lands with their blood and sweat and
toil could have known that a few hundred
years hence their descendants would be
groveling before these indian tribes and
whispering to them thank you for
allowing us to live laugh and love and
do yoga here our answers probably would
have just turned around and went home
and said it's not worth the effort
[Music]
so a writer by the name of michelle
psycho highlights what she says is the
worst land acknowledgement she's ever
seen now for those who are unfamiliar
with this cutting edge innovation in the
field of white guilt a land
acknowledgment is something like an act
of contrition that a catholic might say
after confessing his sins to the priest
except in this case the act of
contrition is being offered to some
randomly selected group of indians who
lived on the land in question at some
arbitrary point
in the past
land acknowledgments are meant to
acknowledge that we are allegedly on
tribal land so needless to say
talking about the worst land
acknowledgement it's like discussing the
most unpleasant porta potty you've ever
been in i mean these aren't there aren't
any good ones there they're just varying
degrees of sickening the one presented
here for consideration is from
vancouver island university and it says
vancouver island university acknowledges
that we are on the traditional and
unseated territory of the
oh boy
the snooni
maksu well how do you do that that's xw
how do you pronounce that
anyway territory of these snooni muksu
people and we thank them for allowing us
to live laugh love and learn here
okay i take it back that is probably the
worst
if only the pioneers who conquered these
lands with their blood and sweat and
toil could have known that a few hundred
years hence their descendants would be
groveling before these indian tribes and
whispering to them thank you for
allowing us to live laugh and love and
do yoga here our ancestors probably
would have just turned around and went
home and said it's not worth the effort
why bother bleeding and dying for a
civilization that will one day be
inherited by the most embarrassing
obsequious effeminate weaklings to ever
live on planet earth perhaps that's the
point of all this
the left is punishing their ancestors by
becoming everything their ancestors
would hate
in fact come to think of it that is
exactly the point but we're getting
ahead of ourselves michelle provides
another fun contender for the worst land
acknowledgement this one from the
washington state department of
corrections it reads
the washington state department of
corrections acknowledges that its
facilities offices and operations are on
the ancestral lands and customary
territories of indigenous peoples tribes
and nations corrections
thanks gives thanks to the tribes for
caring for these lands since time
immemorial and honors its ongoing
connection to these communities past
present and future we welcome the
opportunity to collaborate with the
indigenous populations of communities
and strive to work with our tribal
partners to improve the lives of
indigenous people and non-indigenous
neighbors throughout the state
okay you're you're a prison so just calm
down here
but these acknowledgements also come in
video form lucky for you for instance
last week the aspen ideas festival
kicked off with this quirky little
disclaimer listen to this
truth and acknowledgement are the
foundation to healing and transformation
we begin this effort today by
acknowledging that we are in the
ancestral lands of native nations
including the taino the calusa the
tequesta and today the sovereign and
unseated homelands of the seminole tribe
of florida and the mikasuki tribe of
indians of florida
our communities and ways have existed
long before the united states
we have survived attempted takeovers
the indian removal act under andrew
jackson
three seminal wars between 1814 and 1858
being hunted with bloodhounds rounded up
like cattle and forced on the trail of
tears
okay the trail of tears started in 1830
so that's nearly 200 years ago
my ancestors were dying in the potato
famine around that time
but you don't hear me complaining about
it
if you're carrying around grievances
that date back two
centuries
to a time before you or your parents or
your parents parents or your parents
parents parents grandparents parents who
are alive then that tells me that you
have these grievances
because you want them
they're an emotional tool that you like
to use
here's the thing
most human beings on earth today if they
trace their lineage back 200 years
we'll find that their ancestors endured
all manner of unspeakable horrors
deprivations and sufferings but only
some of us
go around talking about it all the time
only some of us feel that our ancestors
struggles must be acknowledged to us
as if we were the ones who suffered
those things
but that wasn't even as bad as the
acknowledgment that now as of last year
is played before every home game for the
chicago blackhawks hockey team listen to
this
the chicago blackhawks acknowledge
that the team its foundation
and the spaces we maintain work and
compete within
stand upon the traditional homelands of
the miami sakh muskwaki ho chunk
menominee
and the council of the three fires the
ojibwe odawa and potawatomi nations
we understand that this land holds
immense significance for its original
stewards the native nations
and the peoples of this region
we would also like to recognize that our
team's namesake sauk war leader
blackhawk serves as a continuous
reminder of our responsibility to the
native american communities we live
amongst
and draw inspiration from
yes it's very important that we pay
homage to the ho-chunk people before a
hockey game i can't tell you how many
times i've been sitting down to watch a
sporting event and thought to myself you
know
it's not fair that we're all enjoying
ourselves here and just completely
ignoring the ho chunks uh it's just i've
said it so many times like it's my my
family they're sick of me saying as i
always say it
they also of course had to pay deference
to uh sauk war leader blackhawk who was
an indian warlord born in the mid 1700s
it'd be quite rude to have a hockey
match without mentioning an indian
warlord from 250 years ago obviously
as a war leader blackhawk um
would have led raiding parties now
do you know what raiding parties did
they weren't throwing parties as we
think of them today i can tell you that
okay these weren't birthday parties they
were raiding parties and raiding meant
stealing from and terrorizing other
tribes often killing their men
kidnapping and raping their women and
their children okay that's what indian
tribes
did so when you hear about an indian
warlord that's what he did
this is how they lived
and of course you know we're obsessed
with problematic uh we we we gotta we
gotta sift through the lives of all the
historical figures tear down the statues
we're worried about problematic
historical figures but the only
historical figures we're still allowed
to honor
are indian warlords from 200 years ago
that raped and killed children
this is what happened in indian tribes
it was the case everywhere without
exception
they stole from each other they killed
they kidnapped they conquered and so on
over and over again century upon century
this is one of the many reasons why this
whole
land acknowledgement thing is is
ludicrous
whose land is it who are we supposed to
be acknowledging
just the most recent tribe to occupy it
before white people showed up but that
tribe stole it from another and that one
from a different tribe and on and on
stretching back into the unknown and
unrecorded past this is not what about
ism this is first of all a simple
historical reality that needs to be
acknowledged speaking of acknowledgments
it's also a logical problem for the for
the white guild brigade
if this is not really our
land if we occupy it illegitimately
because we conquered it then the same
must be said of whatever tribe we took
it from and of whatever tribe they took
it from etcetera the only way to escape
this problem is to suggest that the
white man should be held to a higher
standard
but why is that
the only way to justify a higher moral
standard for the white men is the claim
that the white man is inherently morally
superior but i'm pretty sure that's not
what they mean to say or what they want
us to take away from this
which means then that the same
historical standard applies to everybody
which completely destroys the basis for
all this groveling and apologizing
this land was soaked in the blood of
conquest long before anyone with white
skin ever stepped foot on these shores
the white man joined the fray joined the
fight didn't start it
or at least of all invent the whole
concept
after all what does the word indigenous
even mean
according to the collins dictionary it
means quote people or things that belong
to the country in which they're found
rather than coming there or being
brought there from another country
okay well that means that either um no
one is indigenous here or we all are
because everybody who lives here now
every no exceptions here everyone
who lives
in the americas
is descended from a group that came here
at some point in the past
period
now your ancestors may have came here
come here a thousand years ago they may
have come here 200 years ago two years
ago
but we all came here a nation of
immigrants isn't that what the left
always likes to say now it's not
actually true because the european
settlers came here before it was an
actual nation i mean they came when it
was unsettled wilderness which means
they weren't technically immigrants but
we did all come here that's true
that doesn't mean that we can't or
shouldn't defend and control our borders
no because once you claim and settle a
territory you have to defend it
if you won't or you can't it will cease
to exist
if you have land that you won't or can't
defend
you will not have it for very long
that's the law of history that's the way
of the world the indian tribes played
this same game and understood the rules
it's only we modern people who are
stupid and shallow enough to be
scandalized by it
by the way that land acknowledgement
from the university
has now um
necessitated its own acknowledgment of
the sins committed by the
acknowledgement because the university
posted after that they said we thank
michelle psycho for bringing to our
attention an unofficial land
acknowledgement on our website
we apologize to those who are negatively
impacted by this language
apologizing for an apology
and if anybody was negatively impacted
by the apology for the apology they'll
no doubt apologize for the apology for
the apology
they are stuck now in a
self-perpetuating cycle of groveling
a vortex of cringe
this is the inevitable end result
it's where it always leads
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends